In this class, we'll be
using R to work with data
and build models.
But what is R?
R is a software environment
for data analysis,
statistical computing,
and graphics.
It is also a
programming language
which is natural
to use and allows
you to complete data
analyses in just a few lines.
We won't be doing much
programming in class,
and almost everything
we ask you to do
can be completed in a few lines.
There's a lot more
that you can do with R
than just what we
teach in this class,
but you will have a
good understanding of R
and how to use it
in just a few weeks.
R originated from the
statistical programming
language S, which was
developed by John Chambers
while at Bell Labs in the 1970s.
The first version
of R was developed
by Robert Gentlemen
and Ross Ihaka
at the University of
Auckland in the mid-1990s.
They wanted a better
statistical software
to use in their Macintosh
teaching laboratory
and decided to create their own.
They also released it as an
open-sourced alternative to S
and encouraged others
to download and help
develop the software.
There are many choices
for data analysis
software available today.
In addition to R,
some popular examples
are SAS, Stata, SPSS, Excel and
Excel add-ons, MATLAB, Minitab,
and pandas in Python.
So, why are we using R?
R is free and
open-sourced and is
available on all platforms,
Mac, Windows, and Linux.
R is also widely used.
There are more than two
million users around the world.
This means that new features are
being developed all the time,
and there are a lot of
community resources for R.
Additionally, R makes it
easy to re-run previous work
and to make adjustments.
R also has nice graphics
and visualizations.
We will just be using the
R command line interface.
However, if you would like
to try a graphical user
interface, or GUI,
there are many choices.
Two popular choices
are RStudio and Rattle.
There are many R resources
available online.
In addition to the official
R page and the download page,
there are many helpful websites.
Here are a few popular ones.
In general, though, if
you're looking for a command
or how to do something
in R, try googling it.
Often, if you just try typing
"R" and then what you're
looking for in a
search engine, you
can find some very helpful
posts and websites.
We want to emphasize, though,
that the best way to learn R
is through trial and error.
So, let's get
started working in R.